we get a lot of requests at the moment
for layers
people wanting warm things because
whether they're in or out of the house
even as the seasons change they can't
afford to keep their homes as warm as
they would like
so they want things like that that will
be a lovely cozy thing to keep a child
warm at home
this baby bank in south west london
provides essentials to new parents who
would otherwise go without
they've been a lot busier than usual
increasingly what i've noticed is that a
lot of the referrals are people in work
um perhaps not full-time work but even
though they're working and
everything they're finding that they
can't make ends meet
onesworth has had a conservative run
council for 44 years but labour hoped to
clinch it this time as rising inflation
and energy costs pile pressure on
families
it's the final few days of campaigning
the last ditch attempt to get the vote
out the tories hoping that low council
tax will keep them in
labor that the squeeze on household
finances plus the partygate scandal will
swing it their way
lots of families are
choosing
what what to spend their money on
it's like they say eating or eating
because i actually had a baby in
lockdown so for me to be inside for that
whole time when you're out here having
the time of your life and i can't even
get access to midwife services i can't
get access to anything
labour say they're not expecting to win
here in wandsworth but the polls suggest
they'll make gains in the capital and
other big cities where it's a different
story is in many towns particularly
former industrial areas where they're
struggling to win back lost support
nuneaton's coal mines are long gone and
so it seems is labour's dominance the
conservatives swept to power on the
council last year and their campaign
focuses on a major regeneration of the
town centre there'll be a new hotel site
here
my dad's family moved down to camp hill
in the 1960s
for the mining opportunities and my
grandfather would probably be turning in
his grave if he knew that i was a tory
never mind tory leader of a council i
started off at taking the leadership on
in 2014 and we only had three out of 34
councillors
on eaton and bedworth and we've gone now
to 25 so i think that's a rather
remarkable change
of circumstances in a relatively short
period of time
labour may be past their heyday here but
they're hoping to make modest gains
do you think after losing so many
council seats you can start to claw it
back we'll be giving it every every
effort this coming election it's hard to
get my head around we're with you know
so many areas of deprivation within this
borough
um that we have gone
through blue
as the old rhythms of politics are
shifting
labor's message may resonate in some
parts of the country but is failing to
get a hearing in others tomorrow cohen
sky news